muy buenos días pues y poco a poco
después de que se dio a conocer esta
noticia en un comunicado como se lo
decía muy escueto por parte del inicio
son cada vez más las personas que se van
a poner en cuarentena preventivamente
porque la agenda del presidente macon
durante toda esta semana había estado
bastante apretada el lunes precisamente
en ese encuentro con pedro sánchez pero
el martes el almuerzo con el presidente
de la asamblea nacional y con varios de
los líderes de los grupos políticos de
la asamblea nacional todos ellos también
van a aislarse y justamente el día de
ayer no solamente había cenado con el
primer ministro ron castex que por ahora
pues ha dado negativo sino también con
el primer ministro de portugal antonio
costa quien está a la espera del
resultado de la texto que se le hizo y
pues también de todas maneras va a
aislarse de manera preventiva y el
último es digamos en esta lista porque
prácticamente con el coach pues es como
en un efecto dominó es asia o michel el
presidente del consejo europeo quien no
es considerado como un caso contacto él
estuvo en compañía del presidente marco
el lunes pero que de todas maneras
también va a
aislado de manera preventiva la agenda
del presidente de manuel marco ha sido
completamente cambiada luego de este
diagnóstico la semana próxima él debía
viajar a líbano para pasar con militares
franceses la navidad todo esto pues
hasta ahora claramente ha sido cancelado